you've done a lot of cool stuff through
your career uh if someone has never seen
anything you've worked on or seen any
episodes of anything what is the first
thing you'd like them watching and why
oh my god um that's a tough question
uh I mean that you know what's
interesting is like uh one of the first
things I showed my kids that I had ever
written was a show I wrote for Next
Generation called data day and it
introduced all it was sort of like for
somebody who didn't know what Star Trek
was I thought it was a good introduction
to that world and it was also sort of an
an insight into the character of data
and when I watched it through their eyes
it told me a lot about sort of how I see
the world you know and there's a part of
me that is somewhat data likee of trying
to understand the humanity around me and
sort of trying and not getting all the
social cues all the time and uh and some
ways that that episode is very sort of
uh illuminative of of sort of me on some
level I could talk to you about Star
Trek for the rest of the interview but
I'm here for For All Mankind and I got
tons of questions so every time I've
spoken to you and it's been almost every
season I asked the same question and I
will ask it today uh when are we getting
the
Starship we're getting there getting
closer all the time man this is the
season where it's like this is where the
season becomes you're introducing sci-fi
elements to the show while still staying
grounded so now we're it's just a matter
of time yeah I think you're you're we're
definitely on that trajectory yes I
agree so do you think I know you have a
seven season plan in the seven season
plan did does the words Starship shows
up or is it it's it's it's uh it is
certainly talked about I won't give away
whether it's it's firmly in our plan or
not so I did a long interview with Matt
and Ben and I asked them and I will ask
you you um is For All Mankind
essentially the prequel show to the
eventual Star Trek show of For All
Mankind like we're getting the seven
seasons and then all of a sudden there's
a spin-off show that's two 300 years
later and that's the Starship show uh
you never know we haven't really talked
about in those terms we certainly talk
about it thematically as the Star Trek
prequel of like you know how do you get
to the optimistic kind of world that
Star Trek lives in you know that kind of
future and that matters to us like okay
here's Star Trek had posited this this
amazing future that we all kind of want
to be a part of but how do you get there
and so the show set out to sort of lay
out the groundwork of how you get there
now whether the show actually does get
there and then has its own kind of
Adventure like that is is kind of a
separate question that we haven't really
tackled oh I know that's the reason I
will keep asking it yes because you know
so I've seen the first seven episodes of
season 4 they're fantastic I love this
show so much uh what are you most
excited for fans to actually see this
season I'm really interested in the the
Margo storyline of you know Margo's life
behind the Iron Curtain you know seeing
her uh struggling by herself and you
know she they saved her they kept her
out of jail and then they just kind of
put her on an iceberg and she's been
sort of there by herself and no one's
really taking her phone calls anymore
and yet she's determined to work her way
back into to aace program oneway shape
or form and I think that's an really
interesting Journey for the character
and I think it's also just interesting
to see how the Soviet Union has has
evolved sort of this in this alternate
timeline one of the things you got to do
this season is you guys filmed in
Eastern Europe specifically for her
storyline and it adds so much because
you never feel like you're in LA right
yeah that was really important that when
we shot those scenes that you did feel
like we were someplace else talk a
little bit about so one of the things is
uh have you guys talked to Apple that
God forbid you're not going to get
renewed they tell you so you can sort of
wrap something up or you never had that
conversation with them uh we've never
really had that conversation with them
they've you know they've been very
supportive of the show from the very
beginning and we've never felt you know
the sort of damle hanging over our head
you know in in the series so far so you
know either either that we're really
lucky or we're just fools and you never
know one of the things is that this
season and I said it earlier is where
you guys are starting introducing
science fiction elements but you the
thing is you always try to keep it as
grounded as you can can you talk about
where how you're willing to add sci-fi
to it or just in general adding sci-fi
to the show finally well you know I mean
by its nature we're in science fiction
territory because we're doing things
like moon bases and Mars bases that
never existed and different kinds of
spacecraft and propulsions and nuclear
fusion so almost by definition it's a
science fiction Universe right and the
further we go down this road the more it
diverges from the original timeline the
more deeply science fiction uh the show
becomes in that capacity however we're
still it's still really important to us
that we keep it grounded and that it's
all feels real and all feels plausible
so there's not you know we don't have
aliens suddenly showing up in the show
and they don't discover alternate
dimensions and time travel and certain
other s you know sci-fi tropes that we
have a specific uh narrow band of
Science Fiction uh that we're trying to
go down and we it's it's important to us
that we stay within our lane one of the
things I really like Toby's character
and I'm not going to spoil anything but
um he opens the door to a whole another
aspect of space and For All Mankind it
feels like this is the season that's
taking a new door if you will can you
sort of talk about that aspect of the
show and whatever you want to tease for
Toby's character yeah I mean Toby plays
a character called miles and miles is a
civilian who was a oil rig worker on
Earth Earth and as the fossil fuel
industry started to uh decline because
of the uh development of nuclear fusion
and green energy on Earth fossil fuel
jobs started to go away so he's sort of
you know he's one of the losers in that
situation even though the planet's
getting better there are certain people
that are going to be out of jobs and and
are going to going to suffer for it so
he comes from that and he's looking for
just a way to keep his family afloat a
way to make money and he by hook and by
crook he he manages to get a job with
Helios on Mars and that opens up the
world of uh of Mars and labor on Mars
and sort of The Upstairs Downstairs
quality of well there's the astronauts
and then there's the civilians and
they're not there for the same reasons
and they their working conditions are
very different the way they look at each
other culturally is very different how
they get paid is very different and the
these the conflict between those two
groups was something we were really
interested in uh exploring this year and
miles's character was the great way to
sort of you know get a window into that
world what do you think would surprise
fans of the show to learn about either
the behind the scenes of the show or the
actual making of the show I think they'd
be surprised to see how much of it is
shot in Los Angeles that Mars is really
a sound stage and you know how difficult
it is to pull this off week after week
it's a tremendous amount of work by a
lot of people a lot of different
departments to realize this and if you
were with us like at the beginning of
each season you'd see everybody
scrambling to essentially make a new
show because we have to reinvent all the
sets new costumes there's new casts
coming in older cast has to you know how
are we doing their old age makeup we
have to brand new spaceships have to be
designed every year the Mars base has to
be reconstructed and rebuilt and it's
really an enormous undertaking every
year to just really make it a brand new
show I say this as a hardcore fan I am
very thankful for all of your long hours
um I know you're involved in about a
thousand things so what else are you
working on right now I I you know I I'm
working at several shows at 20th Century
which is part of of Disney now and I'm
developing a few shows for for Disney
plus and you know nothing has been green
lit because we're all still kind of
waiting for the the last strike to to
sort of resolve but I'm very hopeful and
we we'll see what develops over the
course of the next year Matt and Ben
told me that this is the first time that
a writer room hasn't been ready for the
next season or hasn't been worked on due
to the strike so um is there any
movement I spoke to them a week or two
ago has there been any movement in the
week or two about season five uh there's
definitely been more conversation about
it yeah think you can sense things are
starting to pick up and people are you
know just industrywide everyone's
starting to gear up towards okay we know
it's about to all happen again so let's
start talking in Earnest about how we
make uh how we prepare the way for it on
that note I need to stop sir I really am
a fan of your work wish you nothing but
the best thank you good to see
you